[Musique]
et on commence ces informations Gabriel
par la Banque alimentaire qui lance sa
grande collecte annuelle demain oui
Mathilde elle se déroule les 24 25 et 26
novembre comme chaque année vous
pourrait retrouver les bénévoles équipés
de leur gilet orange dans de nombreux
magasins pour récupérer des produits
alimentaires et d'hygiène l'en passé
l'initiative avait permis de couvrir 10
% des besoins d'approvisionnement soit
24 millions de repas pour la Banque
Alimentaire Paris Île-de-France 117000
bénévoles sont déjà mobilisés une
collecte d'autant plus importante avec
l'inflation car les prix des ressources
augmentent ce qui fragilise la Banque
Alimentaire vous pouvez aider la
collecte pour sa rendez-vous sur le site
je veux aider.gv on poursuit ces
informations avec une pétition lancée
par le maire des clés sous-bois Philippe
guigen oui après le courrier la pétition
Philippe guigen appelle tous les élus de
France à signer et à relayer cette
pétition pour engager une réforme des
mécanismes financiers en octobre dernier
on le rappelle il avait déjà adressé un
courrier au président de la République
pour dénoncer le désengagement de l'État
sur les finances des collectivités
locales et malgré le réchauffement
climatique nous serions de plus en plus
nombreux dans les iblelines à avoir une
voiture oui Mathilde je vous en parlais
d'après une étude de liinc plus on
s'éloigne de la capitale plus la part
des ménages équipée d'une voiture
augmente en 2019 le taux d'équipement
automobile dans la grande couronne était
de 80 3,4 % pour 33,5 % à Paris et alors
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer cet
écart et ben justement selon l'INC tout
dépend du profil du ménage les personnes
qui vivent au moins avec un actif ou qui
résident dans une maison détiennent le
plus souvent une voiture l'âge du ménage
a aussi son importance car à partir de
55 ans le taux d'équipement automobile
progresse on poursuit avec une bonne
nouvelle Gabriel le 30 novembre prochain
Paris 2024 mais en vot en vente 400000
nouveaux billets pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 oui une bonne
nouvelle et il faudra être à l'heure
parce que les places sont sont seront
mises en vente sur le site de paris 2024
à 10h elles sont prévues pour assister à
n'importe quelle compétition sportive
sauf le surf car la réservation n'est
pas obligatoire sachez que la vente
concernera aussi les rencontres qui
étaient en rupture de stock pour ce qui
est des prix Mathilde ils sont plutôt
abordable un/ers des billets seront à 50
€ et près de 2 tiers à moins de 100 €.
j'ai déjà mis une alerte sur mon
téléphone personnellement d'autres
billets sont aussi mis en vente Gabriel
ce sont ceux de l'Electric Park festival
oui il s'agit des passes confiance si
vous faites confiance aux organisateurs
et que vous souhaitez prendre vos places
avant même de connaître la programmation
c'est possible et ce dès maintenant ces
passe confiance VIP comprennent des
espaces privés des bars ou encore un
accès gratuit aux animations les billets
sont disponibles sur shotgun.live le
festival aura lieu les 30 et 31 août
2024 vous avez peu le temps merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous l'envoyer
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 7we news